I'm terrified of regret I don't want to
I don't want to live with regret so I
make the decision from I'm about I'm on
my deathbed I'm looking back will I
regret doing this or not doing this and
it's very rarely the things that we
would regret doing it's the actions not
taken I think that we could have done
that we did were you afraid to do so I
try to make that fear of regret so big
that of course as a manager and I could
deal with it not working I could deal
with the failure but I couldn't deal
with not knowing the Rolling Stones in
their 70s still playing music from the
60s I admire that they're still out
singing but like you haven't come up
with a new song for like 20 years I
don't want to be the agent rock star I'm
gonna be an aging badass reading about
how you had the opportunity to go become
a banker yeah in New York yeah but you
chose to pursue entrepreneurship yeah
and you know everyone always has two
options in life that really will pull
them and I want to get your take on how
should somebody go about choosing like
making such a big decision that you did
and how you felt in that process so the
two things that really guided me to help
make that decision and it wasn't an easy
decision there's probably the most
difficult decision of my life one is big
decisions with your heart and small ones
with your head your head feeling your
stay in a world that currently exists
where your heart can create something
new and so if you sit there and you're
making a list of pros and cons it's a
losing mentality because you can't think
your way through something that should
be with the heart so you know what
opportunity you chase what girl you date
shouldn't be based on well if this
checklist of perfect things it's like
how do I feel about her how do you feel
about this opportunity so big decisions
always with the heart and then your head
will help you figure out how to make it
happen because sometimes a lot what your
heart wants to do doesn't make any sense
so there you got to make your brain your
ally because often it's against you to
begin it's a big scary crazy thing that
you should be doing that your heart
tells you to do doesn't make any sense
so your heads working against you
they're opposite so you make it with
your heart and then you let your head
say okay heart okay head we're doing
this
how should we do it and your head will
figure out the other ones just regret
I'm terrified of regret I don't want to
I don't want to live with regret so I
make the decision from I'm about I'm on
my deathbed I'm looking back will I
regret doing this or not doing this and
it's very rarely the things that we were
regret doing it's the actions not taken
I think that we could have done that we
did that we were afraid to do so I try
to make that fear of regret so big that
it forces me to action mm-hmm and so
where did your did you just always
believe that you could do that and
become an entrepreneur and succeed no I
mean I want to be a banker you know
entrepreneurship was not part of my
culture growing up my family my
environment my friends we weren't you
know heavily intelligent ownership I
also wasn't as popular you know the lady
these really 90s when I was getting
started
it was just by me saying yes to join in
a company instead of taking a job only
because I thought I might regret it that
was it it's like I'm gonna say yes to
being in a startup and owning a piece of
a company because I knew I could go get
another job I didn't know if I can get
the same job with the same pay but I can
get something close but this opportunity
I didn't know if I'd ever get again so I
had to do it and I could deal with it
not working I could deal with the
failure but I couldn't deal with not
knowing so I try to use that as my frame
of reference Elvis it's so interesting
because I feel like everybody knows this
including myself when you get caught up
in the moment and you know you're gonna
regret something so why do you think
people even though they know they're
gonna regret it later on laughs why you
think even with the common sense they
just they don't do it because they think
that the immediate pain is greater than
the micro pains all the time because the
pain of
like the pain right now doing that thing
might be level 50 but the pain of like
just suffering tomorrow is just one but
then another one the next day and
another one the next another one so that
adds up those ones every day I'd up to
like two million but because those two
million are so far away you don't think
of it as that painful and you just see
the 50 in front of you as this huge
number and so what I try to do is make I
try to I try to get the two million I
try to make the two million like 20
million and bring it back to the day
like this is gonna be the greatest thing
of all time then I'm gonna miss out on
if I don't do it so that's why choice do
you always do something every day to get
out of your comfort zone on that level
or is it I also probably don't do enough
I probably on doing that I mean I don't
think anybody does enough to be honest I
what I what I do might be at a high
level compared to what most people do
but I but I don't very much give myself
credit for being like always on the edge
and always taking risk because I feel
like I can do more mm-hmm and going back
to what you said about not doing enough
do you think that's one of the because
you're a very or a very humble person
and you you've achieved such amazing
success but to yourself here nowhere
near you need to go do you feel like
that is what makes you so successful
like not looking at the success really
that often so I think I think you need
to be your biggest critic and your
biggest fan I think we tend to default
into one or the other I think you need
to be both I think some people are their
biggest critic and you're really hard on
yourself but you also have to love
yourself and think you're amazing and I
think some people love themselves so
much and they think everything they do
is fire but they never criticizes so
they never actually grows like why am I
not growing I'm amazing well like you're
actually not that amazing all right yeah
and so I'm usually in a public way very
humble and very not self-deprecating but
like I need the girl I need to get
better I need to improve I need to keep
going and often that means that people
come back to me and they say
don't worry like you're doing so well
like you're amazing really talking about
I got me I'm awesome my channel should
have a Nobel Peace Prize it's like I'm
great but I don't lead with that because
I that's at the core I know I'm amazing
and so I don't question that so then
when I'm critical I live mostly in the
critical I want to get better but it's
all based off of a foundation of I'm
amazing so when you're watching my
videos are giving feedback all I want to
hear is I gotta get better how do i
improve how do I make it I want the
critical stuff and it doesn't rock me
because I think I'm great so I think
what people fall into one of the two
camps you need people your biggest fan
in the biggest way and like going along
that journey was it were you always
willing to accept the criticism or is
that something you cultivated along the
way and it just got easier and easier
were you always so I think it's like a
stress test like at the beginning it's
hard to deal with but you don't get that
much of it when I'm making videos it was
harder to deal with the criticism but I
wasn't getting that many views I wasn't
getting that much hate either so it
became you know you you grow like you
I'm not walking into trying to lift a
thousand pounds I'm gaining muscle as I
go now the haters are greater right now
but I have tons of I've way more fans
and I'm also stronger and able to take
it so I think you acquire those skills
as you grow in circuits and feedback
yeah definitely and for your YouTube
channel I know your goal is to impact a
billion entrepreneurs and you want to
unlock all the potential within
entrepreneurs so it I find that really
interesting because and I know you even
talk about like you know you're never
going to attain that goal in life and
yet you still set it for yourself and
that motivates you and energizes you and
that goes against conventional wisdom
about you know setting a mission that
you can read
because you're never gonna reach it so
how does that how does that motivate you
how does that how does that drive you if
you know you're never gonna be able to
see the outcome never be able to taste
the success in that because the goal is
not to reach the goal the goal is the
process of reaching the goal so I use
analogy of swimming I'm swimming in an
ocean I never want to reach the island I
want to swim forever as one of the
happen is you you reach the island and
then what you're happy for a second and
then you're upset when you hit your goal
you're happy for an hour and then okay
now one everything you've tied your
identity to achieving this goal you've
done it and now you feel sad now you've
got a they need a new ball and so what I
want to do is not just time I like it
maybe takes you three years to get to
that first goal yeah I did it and then
okay well now what do I do
I don't want to I don't want to tie my
identity to these one every three year
one our moments of happiness I want to
enjoy the swim so I don't wanted a big
island and is that is that only through
realization and through experience of
setting these goals and realizing
they're not cracked up to what they be
yeah like yeah and I think I just I
don't even celebrate I celebrate for the
fans people are like when you hit a
million you're gonna do anything oh yeah
we should probably do something right
it's like it's nothing it's like I'm
already I want to be out here it's still
small but but I think it's a I think
that's still the loving yourself and
being the critic like I got to love my
fans as hard as name on myself it helps
them to celebrate so I celebrate for
them but it doesn't mean much to me
because I want to be I'm moving on like
great milestone next so when did I hit a
million I don't know like I'm not I
don't pay attention to those things I'm
only looking in in forward direction not
rearview mirror yeah all the content I
see it's all moving forward or all
pushing out content so fast one of the
things that bothers me one of the things
that I'm terrified of is living off my
back catalogue like the Rolling Stones
in their 70s still playing music from
the 60s I admire that they're still out
singing but like you haven't come up
with a new song for like 20 years
that terrifies me like the video that I
put up today I want to be like my newest
video when I'm 70 I want to be making
insanely epic content that like puts
whatever I'm doing today the shame I
don't want to rely on my back catalogue
I want to keep swimming
no no I think I think those successful
people get complacent they stop losing
their ambition I think that's it like we
did everything we hit our goals we
played the stadiums you did the big
things that we wanted to do and then you
don't know what to do next yeah I know I
never want that there's always in that
there's always something like the best
is tomorrow the best is still to come I
think yeah thought so though like I look
I look at the I look at aging rock stars
as motivation like they gave up they
stopped to hit the apex in their 30s
they did the tours they made their money
and then they give up I don't want that
so everything I do now is like the worse
that I'm doing it's only gonna get
insanely better right now I don't always
make it insanely better but it's always
my intention it's always mind like maybe
this interview sucks but it's always my
intention to make it the best that I can
do right now with my abilities right and
if you go every day trying with that
intention to make it happen then you
will make some things happen but if you
give up you hit your goal hey okay I
don't want to be the agent Rock step I'm
gonna be an aging badass making crazy
crazy content and I see that I see that
drives every so presen that really
motivates me to try and aspire to do
similar things and looking at all the
content and posting up and innovating so
much and trying to aspire to do
everything you want to do I you can
correct me if I'm wrong but I view you
as obsessed no longer passionate so I
want to get your thoughts on obsession
versus passionate like do you feel like
there's a difference and do you feel
like to get to the level that you are
through for instance my eyes and the
level where you need to go and the
people you put on your channel do you
feel like passion is enough to get you
there that you need to become obsessed I
really struggle with labels like I spend
zero time thinking about this stuff like
are you an entrepreneur or not can you
be an entrepreneur if you're in a
corporation I don't know do you think
you're an entrepreneur
yes like let's not spend time on this
let's go so so passionate versus
obsessed is like a hard is a hard thing
for me so I'm like working through it as
I'm talking out loud because I don't
spend any time thinking about it well no
I I think I think it's a terrible
question but I want to bring value right
because my default answer is like I
don't spend don't spend any time on it
like you want something go get it
stop stop for it because that my fear is
somebody says well I'm passionate but
I'm not obsessed like stop thinking and
just go do yeah don't worry you're
obsessed with you're not passionate like
go make get out of your head and create
go go go
that's what I want to say but I also
want to like I want to I want to take it
a level deeper and I'm struggling to
like connect to it anyway that brings
value to to the audience here well just
in terms of like sacrificing and because
you've definitely had to sacrifice a lot
I find to get to a certain level yeah I
mean Jerry Seinfeld calls it's a torture
you can endure I like that I think it's
I think if I stepped in your schedule I
should find a torturous like it's
torture like whatever you do like oh I
hate my life because it's so intense and
people jumping into what I do should be
torture I think you got to find the
thing that you love so much
that the process the swimming this is a
swimming how many people watch this I
don't care this this is what this is
what you need to pay attention to we're
swimming
if 18 people watch this or 18 million
I'm not attached to it I'm not talking
to you because this video has to blow up
or not like this is the process and so
find the thing that you love doing that
you can forget to eat and forget to pee
and forget to have anything right yeah
and then then like when you turn it off
you want to fall apart like I'm gonna go
home and just die on the bed I think
that's healthy
that's the formula find the thing that
you use you are dying doing but you
don't know you're dying other people
would die instantaneously and then when
you stop it
you feel like you're gonna die but that
was the answer right there yes I was
perfect thank you so much
cool yes definitely blessing if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon this
interview was done as a part of my
Toronto workshop if you want more
details on the next one to sign up check
out the link right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there